beschwerlich ist der weg zum treffpunkt
und
im gestrüpp sind die männer in ihrer tat
montur kaum auszumachen sie haben die
nacht im eisigen winter wald be back
irrt denn sie sollen einen hinterhalt
legen es sind angehörige des estnischen
freiwilligen kurs und jeder hat seine
eigenen gründe bei dieser mehr übung
mitzumachen
[Musik]
man lernt ja hier auch viele praktische
dinge über geografie logistik und
mathematik
und nicht nur über gewehre minen und
granaten
oktobers ist 36 und eigentlich it
fachmann
sonderlich brenzlig findet ihr die
politische lage nicht aber man kann ja
nie wissen und es ist besser vorbereitet
zu sein
irgendwo auf der welt ist schließlich
immer krieg aber ich glaube dass sie uns
im moment nicht angreifen wollen
jetzt muss sich der kleine trupp neu
aufstellen denn es nähert sich ein
konvoi der invasoren den sollen sie
überfallen
berufssoldaten dirigieren die übung
stoppt also noch mal ganz langsam zwei
fahrzeuge lassen wir passieren aber das
dritte das nehmen wir unter feuer
über 20.000 mitglieder hat die estnische
heimwehr sie sollen die reguläre armee
unterstützen mit reaktionen und
partisanenkrieg ein stolperdraht gegen
eine übermächtige invasionsarmee
[Musik]
die hätte wohl schon am ersten tag die
hauptstadt tallinn mit ihrer malerischen
altstadt erreicht
die russische gewaltherrschaft frühere
jahre haben noch viele estnische
politiker nicht überlebt einige porträts
schmücken die amtsstuben von kayak
ahlers der premierministerin
wir kennen die geschichte in trier
kennen unseren nachbarn wenn die russen
die ukraine angreifen dann ist das auch
für uns bedrohlich
vor allem unsere ältere bevölkerung hat
die sowjetzeit erlebt und will die
russen nicht wieder hier haben wir
fühlen sie sich von der nato ausreichend
geschützt
das ist wie auf dem schulhof wenn dich
da in röbel bedroht und du hast starke
freunde dann passiert dir nichts und
unser starker freund ist die nato in
nature
draußen im winterwald ist der starke
freund im einsatz
der feindliche konvoi den geheimen und
übungs halber überfällt das sind nato
soldaten aus frankreich
[Applaus]
nach dem angriff ziehen sich die kämpfer
sofort ins unterholz zurück mehr als
nadelstiche können sie nicht
verabreichen
der ausbilder ist zufrieden und
freiwilligen voller adrenalin
so eine aufregung wie hier draußen in
den wäldern das bekommt man ja nicht
alle tage
wenig aufregung herrschte nahe war ganz
im osten estlands
60.000 einwohner 95 prozent sind
russisch
der zweite weltkrieg hat vom alten aber
nicht viel übrig gelassen dann kam die
sowjetzeit mit ihren plattenbauten
nur die massiven alten festungs welle
sind heil geblieben rechts die
russischen bauern links die letzte
bastion der eu
hier trennt also wirklich nur eine
brücke die europäische union von
russland
so ein preis fischer sehe ich ein
heruntergekommenes fabrikgebäude aber
ansonsten nicht viel aber da geht schon
bei dem wetter auf die straße
dabei gehen manche unerschrockene sogar
ins wasser
russisches fitnesstraining im grenzfluss
rentner bleibt die männer zu ziehen
fürchtet nicht die kälte und auch keinen
krieg
wenn alle unter das dach der amerikaner
wollen steht russland plötzlich in der
badehose da so funktioniert kapitalismus
marx und engels wussten das schon vor
150 jahren aber die werden sich schon
einige europa und die deutschen das sind
doch vernünftige leute
vielleicht wundern sich die russischen
grenzwächter über die ungleichen
spaziergänger auf der estnischen seite
in aber ist jedenfalls keine klare
auskunft über loyalitäten zu gewinnen
so alles hängt von den ukrainern ab wenn
sie provozieren kriegen sie halt einen
drauf
ich bin russin aber hier geboren ich
weiß gar nicht für wen ich mich
entscheiden soll
die vorteile der eu mitgliedschaft
wissen sie zu schätzen hier wo die
grenze so nahe ist kaum einer würde
gerne dauerhaft die seiten wechseln ins
trostlose yvonne burand auf der anderen
seite
denn in estland europas breitband
paradies hat die zukunft längst begonnen
zum beispiel im startup zentrum von java
den örtlichen labor für e business & co
working da treffe ich ivan 21 der träumt
von einer karriere als
internet-unternehmer von investoren und
vom nasdaq seine welt ist global
meine muttersprache ist russisch aber
ich spreche auch estnisch und englisch
und verstehe deutsch und habe auf der
uni spanisch kurse belegt
ich bin russe ein russisch sprechender
erste und viele hier sagen dass man sich
die würde er europas freiheit gegen
putins russland eintauschen
wer das will dem sage ich da ist die
brücke auf wiedersehen
übrigens ivan auch wenn er russisch
spricht ist freiwilliges mitglied der
estnischen heimwehr
die hat inzwischen ihre überfall übung
im wald abgeschlossen und trifft sich
friedlich mit den nato soldaten aus
frankreich
ein foto noch zur erinnerung an einen
denkwürdigen tag in unruhiger zeit wie
alle lieber schnell vergessen würden